rich great to have you on you're out in
canton it must be uh it must be a thrill
for you just to be there i know how much
fun this weekend is how much you enjoy
it and to switch gears now from
the world of the olympics into full
football heaven what's it like to be out
there in ohio
yeah it is it is pretty cool being here
i mean it's the first place
um uh i the first i guess
assignment that i had um
with nfl network actually came out here
the summer before we went on the air
um in 2003 and it was the 40th
anniversary of the hall of fame
and you know it was just a wild
experience for me for many reasons you
know i covered the baseball hall of fame
um um for years and
you know the baseball hall of fame in
cooperstown new york
where there's like one stoplight and
it's like a rockwell painting and then
you come here and
i-77 is you know uh
right across the street from the hall of
fame it's got like the
the the rock man out front looks like
the thing from the fantastic four
and uh and it's just like a totally
different vibe
it's like football you know you're just
coming to hit you in the mouth
um and you know i've watched this place
grow
i mean it just gets bigger every year
and this year
you know is the biggest class ever due
to the pandemic
along with the fact that there was that
that class of 2020
that went uh in with 20 names um
and um so a lot of people have been
waiting
uh for their entire lives and career and
then some an extra year for this moment
and tonight's the jacket dinner i'm
heading to the
uh civic center in about a couple hours
to go through it and it's going to be
unlike any other because normally it's
like a class of
six seven eight sitting on a daze now
there's
you know there's 21 speeches to get
through over the weekend so
it's going to be unique interesting and
also something that hopefully never
happens again
you know absolutely um rich uh i hope
brockman gets to
get back to that dinner because the way
he speaks about that event oh my gosh
it's it's he just ear to ear smile
uh when brian he was talking about it
yesterday he was getting fired up for
that event um
well you know it's it's it's pretty
unique
uh ben and the fact that you know the
hall of fame
the pro football hall of fame there's
three tangible items
that um an enshrinee gets
and it's the bust which everyone knows
about which is revealed right before
they give their speech
it's their hall of fame ring which is
what they get
um at the stadiums when they're fed by
their teams that they're
that they're most familiar you know with
um although i'm wondering if charles
woodson gets two you know uh
peyton manning's definitely gonna get
two denver and indianapolis and
you know we could go on down the list
but um
there's a ring that they get and then
there's the jacket
the gold jacket and that's the first
item that they get
so before there's a speech before
there's a bust they get the jacket
and that's when it really hits them it's
like anybody who's been married it's
when you look down and see the wedding
ring for the first time
um or an engagement ring for the first
time
uh it's like when you get uh when you
have a kid you don't know what it feels
like until the
child is put in your arms like this
truly is like that where
dreams are realized that you're in the
hall of fame
and it it's becomes tangible for the
first time with the jacket
and the moments that are witnessed in
front of everybody are raw
and emotional i remember hank stram who
did not give a speech the year that he
went in uh but recorded it because he
had trouble speaking
finally got in and he got up there and
his
kids were with him and they're the ones
who put the jacket on him
and they um they huddled up and they
cried together
i'm getting goosebumps just recalling it
um
shannon sharp went in and his brother
sterling who
you know was uh on a heck of a
trajectory before he got hurt
um sterling put the jacket on his
brother and it was
obvious that shannon was going into the
hall for both of them
and um and the neat part about all of
this is
it's in front of all the returning hall
of famers who are there as well
um which leads to also the cool moments
that
you know brockman and i and certainly
del tufo from his years
with the network as well we're able to
witness as well which is the the old and
the new
coming together and a perfect example of
this was deacon jones
was alive at the time when shannon went
in the hall
and the the moment of sterling and
shannon hugging each other was in the
front
page of the photograph of the canton
repository
and i think i i witnessed this brockman
i think it's because we were shooting
our podcast show there
yeah across across the hallway i
witnessed this in the lobby
hotel which was deacon
holding up the front page of the
newspaper
to shannon and sterling and profanely
hazing them for crying in front of other
people and it was
i can't repeat what he said
i've ever seen you know and and and
that's what this is about
it's just like errors and um
um also you know generations coming
together
and and it's also the kickoff to a
season now we're you know training camps
are up and running we saw a preseason
game last night
and um you know the juices are flowing
man it's a pretty neat weekend
it's emotional for me rich watching
these guys get inducted this year
because i'm getting to that time
in my life where these are the players
from my childhood charles woodson's why
i applied to michigan that's why i
wanted to go to michigan
because of charles woodson how do you
tell the story of football with charles
woodson what is his place in the history
of the game you think
well it's interesting he's going in with
peyton manning tonight because it was
manning who he beat out for the heisman
in in that performance that maybe made
you want to go to
school and so it's kind of interesting
that they're the two that are going to
be bringing up
the finish the big finish for the
weekend tomorrow
because they're part of the the current
class that goes in 2020 is going to have
their say mostly tomorrow
um and uh you know what he meant for
michigan
playing both ways like legit um
and then he's kind of like dion dion
always called himself a five
down player three on defense
then one receiving the punt and then
first down on offense
you know that's what charles was in
college and then you know went to the
raiders and was a brash young man and
then
you know became a grown ass man and
one of the greatest plays in the history
of the nfl occurred with the
two greatest players in the history of
michigan in the same backfield on a
snowy night
in new england you can't make that sort
of stuff up and the fact that brady will
be there watching charles go
in because he's part of peyton manning's
personal
entourage and class this and and group
um it's going to be star-studded man
because rogers i think is coming for
charles
um it's going to be an incredible
weekend
and boy our cameras are just going to be
looking in
on stuff and it's i'm i'm really
looking forward to it in terms of just
things that you just mentioned ben about
you know players that you remember
growing up watching
troy polamalu who um announced he he was
uh covered positive about a week to a
week and a half ago i don't know if he's
going to be here
i hope he is and um and i hope he's fine
and healthy
um paula malo is the first player to go
into the pro football hall of fame whose
entire career
um has has took place in the history of
nfl network
he's the first guy who came in after the
networks was
on the air and then you know retired
years later we've never had that before
and so it's a big one for us
as a group here um as well that
this is going to be year 19 for nfl
network
season 19 and um our
our 18th anniversary is coming up um
in november palomar was the first for us
so it's pretty cool
rich eisen kind enough to call into the
rich eisen show ben lyons filling in for
rich and
and i hate to tell you rich when you
come back to los angeles we have a flood
here in the studio because
tj has been shedding cowboy tears all
morning long
jerry on stage together talking about
making sports history has tj
all in his feelings so the studio with
cowboys tears
were you as emotional as tj was last
night watching those guys reconnect
oh josh is you when jimmy's liking you
is it gonna happen before i'm dead
you know it was kind of cool you know
yeah i mean you know that was a great
moment and also
an outstanding flex by fox last night
to have all those jackets up there with
troy
and jerry flanking uh jimmy for that
moment
to him say that he's in the ring of
honor
i'm glad they can laugh about it now
because that's a lot of water under that
bridge man
um so you know but i'm more concerned
about jack's
arm aren't you tj well
i mean apparently they he said it wasn't
the shoulder as much as it was something
a muscle or something
underneath the shoulder so i don't know
who knows rich it's too early to be
worried though it's too early
how about this how about this tj this
one's just for you
okay i'm here this one's just for you
and to the rest of everybody else
in the studio a preemptive you're
welcome
all right let me get comfortable for
this who
throws in a game
that counts first
that's prescott or jacob degrom
wow that's so mean
wow you so i don't want anyone else's
hands so you're in can't know how
rich eyes and then you woke up this
morning and you chose violence that was
on the menu like
you looked at your breath you looked at
your breakfast menu and said i have
violence today
is that it it's just clearly tj i've
been staring outside of windows
of hotel rooms in three different cities
now over the span of
three weeks yeah i know some of them
forced by health public health concerns
and others just you know me just trying
to
make ends meet so you you tell me i want
an answer from you
all right what was the question again
who throws who throws a ball in a game
that counts in the standings first
oh that's definitely going to be jake
that's the groan uh
i don't know about that i've got him in
my fantasy league coupe by the way and
van came home from camp today
yeah they're they're nice so cooper coop
will get to his fantasy team
and they'll take a look and zam will see
that the grom
on uh on tell it to the judge which is
the name of our fantasy team together
looks like we're talking about early
september
and we all know jack and the cowboys
play the first thursday of the season
i'm now
i'm now giving you one last chance do
you think
it's really to grow i thought degrom was
about a three week thing
uh now you're saying september
i don't know rich like i i i have no
idea
they reached out they reached out
apparently to like the rangers
training staff to try and help them with
you know when you're talking lots of
muscles underneath the armpit or
whatever
oh my goodness yeah i mean i'm all i
know is i was just for you
i was scouting ben danucci last night
really
you and me both you know um
did have a strong clap with that field
goal though i would say his arm's
looking pretty good
strong clap he was pretty fired up last
night i'm gonna be reeling from rich's
shot the rest of this show though i'm
gonna tell you right
such a love of football such a passion
you're there right now at football
heaven but it was great to find out
yesterday that you
also have a deep passion for walking
that was fun to watch you call a walk
have you ever called walking before and
what makes a great walker
here i've never called race walking i've
never called canoeing
kayaking weightlifting handball
um these were all firsts for me these
were all first equestrian
um um artistic swimming you know they
don't call it synchronized anymore
oh table tennis it's not ping pong you
got to be careful about this stuff
people get very sensitive
um so yes it did look like somebody was
holding a a walnut between their butt
cheeks so i actually said those words on
television um and then later on
um that was just the i guess 20
k or something whatever the 20 i don't
know whatever it was a shorter one they
did the longer one last night
did you see that they're not going to
have it anymore because it's like
inhumane
rich it was incredible last night i
watched the highlight package you did
and it changed the stride in my step
this morning i was walking
towards the studios with some maybe some
walnuts in my possession but yeah it was
there was a waddle that was happening
those athletes are incredible and i just
i'm amazed at the thought process of
you wake up one day and you say i want
to be a walker i want i have to do this
you have a higher calling
and you were able to i honor that
greatness in your highlight package i
was very inspired by it if
if anybody hasn't seen it um it's out
there
um but um the race walking
looks kind of like what lamar jackson
looked like when he was going back to
the locker room on that monday night
game is the brown
remember that where he was waving that
poor person who came through the doors
he was trying to get him along
that's kind of what it looks like the
race walking
well you just needed to he was cramping
he needed some more fluids he
needed iv iv everybody
he needed it fast immediately
so walk us through the rest of the
weekend tonight is is the dinner that
you get to m.c at the civic center
and then walk us through the rest of the
weekend and then
and then tonight's jacket tonight's the
jacket dinner
um tomorrow is the um
is the first set of speeches and nights
12 apparently you're slated to talk and
then
nine on sunday and i'm i'm telling you
the word
you know the word has i saw david baker
mention it on good morning football this
week
the plan is to limit these guys to seven
minutes
and start playing music academy awards
how is this going to work it's not
it's i mean i mean i mean you you you
asked i gave you an answer
i don't i mean you have but you have to
put it at least in the mind's eye
because when we first started call you
know doing this event
it was in the daytime like it was
starting new
and then when erv went into the hall of
fame
and his speech began just as the sun was
setting and
the you know the network saw how
dramatic it was
with the lights on yeah everybody's like
that we gotta have this at night now
and then people started talking and
those speeches when you know when
um barry sanders man of you know few
words got up there and said the most
dreaded words in the history of the
event
i have no notes um even he started going
on 12
15 minutes long the year i am seated
because berman
was presenting ralph wilson
um presenting speeches were longer than
than actual induction speeches so they
got rid of the presenters who now are
presenting people in the form of like a
beautiful three-minute video made by nfl
films
i mean they're kind of always trying to
cut it short but now guys who go in
are speaking half an hour i mean jerry
jones and favre went over 40 minutes
when they spoke
yeah kurt warner spoke to like
15 people because he got up there at
like 11 45 at night
they have to do something and i
honestly don't know there will be um old
school guys up there
um who are when they're waiting 25 years
to get in
and they're gonna be having music played
seven minutes in
they're gonna talk over you're gonna
play i'm gonna play off peyton manning
like what are we doing
exactly there's no i but you know what
i'm saying like so if you're gonna play
off
like just as an example you see you're
you're gonna play off
um like who donnie shell
right you're playing him off for
tagliabue like you play him off you play
edrin james off but you won't play
you don't play off peyton because he's
peyton i don't know how they're gonna do
it
but they have to do something he's 21
speaking
that's a lot well i know that no matter
how long charles woodson's speech is i
will be curled up in the fetal position
weeping i can promise you that much i
will be very emotional to see charles
woodson get inducted into the hall
i know i'm with you two it's gonna be
you know we the thursday night game
um on his last night
in um in oakland was one of my favorites
place was nuts he came in actually
on offense and they gave him like an
option pass
like the place would have been just gone
through the roof
if he had actually gotten that ball in
the end zone on that play
and um you know i mean he
i i was year two of sports center when
he when he won the
the heisman and then on nfl network
you know for for all the other
incredible moments of his career
and then at his final game and now here
i am at this hall of fame induction it's
as a wolverine i will speak on behalf of
all maze and blue
directly to that man's face and i i
i look forward to that that will
hopefully get an opportunity to say that
to him on live television rich how many
criminy cracks at ohio state during the
jacket dinner tonight for you
one and a half over under one and a half
i
don't know um i don't know um
how many people are gonna be there it's
gonna be totally different oh okay don't
know how many if
it's just that if i'm gonna i don't know
if it's gonna call for it there's two
reasons why it doesn't call for that
tonight one
is that the vibe in the room is just
different because there's not enough
you know uh ohioans in the room and two
it has been forever since michigan beat
ohio
thanks so much for calling in the show
we really appreciate it we knew we
needed to go down that rabbit hole i
honestly don't know what standing i
have yeah
is that you have the microphone so you
know what i mean so i know that i don't
know if you were there
the night that i did do that um uh
where where you know they would give
away the beer steins
oh yeah you know what i i won the last
time we were there that's right you won
the
you have the beer sign in front of you i
have in front of me it's from ed reed
i have one too yeah so so i think you
know
i'm supposed to read off the number you
know like you're sitting in seat one
it's like a poker table
right like if you're sitting in seat one
seat four
and i'm like the number for the winning
of stein is
four or for all you ohio state
graduates that's between three and five
that's the direction where i think i
still have standing in which to
have my fun academic good part of it
good good yes
i'll read the room read the room buddy
but guys and ben in all honesty if
you've never seen rich and we talked i
think after the show the other day about
this
rich hosting this thing i've been lucky
enough to go i think
two or three times he absolutely
destroys it
i would it is unbelievable he's got
a couple thousand people just eating out
of the palm of his hand it's it's
amazing to watch
yeah well it's a hell of a night it's
just you know the love of football it
just
courses through the veins and the whole
room it's just your
it's pretty cool man so i like i said i
don't know how it looks when i compared
to other ones because of
the number of inductees and i don't know
how many people are returning or how
many people are going to be allowed in
the facility i have no idea
but it would be great i look forward to
it well have fun
uh enjoy yourself be safe and uh we we
look forward to watching and uh we're
sorry we couldn't take your face time
during our really
important production meeting yesterday
we were going over some real real big
stuff for the show when you called in so
we'll get you next time
thanks matt i appreciate it rick johnson
everybody advertising show
brockman and i are like on the sixth
hole from rich
we've gotta look busy on the sixth hall
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here